hey
it's haley so i
recently got the pfo closure done
and it went very smoothly i'm recovering
really well
haley bieber reveals she underwent heart
surgery the new update comes over a
month after her health scare
definitely the scariest moment of my
life it was definitely a really eye
opening thing for me i definitely felt
a lot of anxiety through the situation
right away he asked for somebody to
please call 9-1-1 and get a doctor the
model breaks down the moment she knew
something was wrong and how husband
justin bieber was by her side throughout
the ordeal
basically i was
sitting at breakfast with my husband and
all of a sudden i felt this really weird
sensation that kind of like traveled
down my arm from my shoulder all the way
down to my fingertips justin was like
are you okay and i just
didn't respond because i wasn't sure
haley says she thought these were
symptoms of a stroke but her doctors
discovered that wasn't the case they did
some scans and they were able to see
that i had suffered a small blood clot
to my brain which they labeled and
categorized as something called a tia
basically it's like having a mini stroke
it definitely feels like having a stroke
except my body was able to resolve it
pretty quickly haley then goes on to
share details about her procedure
so the recommendation from my doctors at
ucla was to have a procedure done called
a pfo closure and they travel up to the
heart and they put this small little
button it looks like a little button
that
buttons close the flap in the heart and
then eventually
your heart tissue grows back over um the
closure device and and that's it and
then you have it forever and you
continue on with normal life haley ends
the video by explaining why it's
important to share her truth it's kind
of like hard for me to tell this story
and because it already was like kind of
a public situation and people kind of
knew but they didn't really know the
full story and i and i also wanted to
wait to explain everything until my
procedure was done and finished and um
everything had gone smoothly and was
okay
that's my story that's what happened
following the traumatic experience a
source told et this quote solidified
that justin will always be by haley's
side
it's an amazing feeling the source added
quote haley is his world and he could
never imagine life without her this
brought them closer together than ever
before and it was a reminder for the
both of them to really appreciate each
other in their special relationship
[Music]